il reste quelques minutes pour parler du
second tome des mémoires de jean marie
le pen
le premier était consacré à la première
partie de sa vie ça s'arrêtait en 1972
parce que c'est la date de la création
de son parti le front national alors
jean marie le pen est supposé être à la
retraite pourtant il reste encore assez
actif d'abord il sort ce livre ensuite
il intervient assez volontiers dans les
médias il était ce matin sur france
inter
et il a commencé par parler de jacques
chirac on se souvient qu'en 2002 il
s'était retrouvé face à lui au second
tour de la présidentielle
et quand on compare chirac et de gaulle
jean marie le pen tous un peu vous avez
vu le sondage dimanche dernier qui dit
qu'il est le président préféré avec de
gaulle ça vous surprend
oui ça me choque un peu parce que je
crois qu'il ya eu un amour varie
médiatique formidable organisée autour
de ces obsèques de sa disparition
alors qu'en fait ils été retiré de la
politique depuis plusieurs années au
lendemain de l'enterrement il ne reste
plus grand chose
alors jean marie le pen parents général
français très précis on se permettant de
lui signaler que hourvari c'est un terme
de chasse qui signifie pour un gibier
revenir sur sa propre trace il a
peut-être confondu avec charivari en
tout cas il parle évidemment dans ce
livre de sa fille marine marine qui
d'ailleurs a répondu à la question qu'on
vous pose lirez vous le tome 2 ll a
répondu que non et quand
on voit comment jean marie le pen parle
de sa fille on peut la comprendre
rinne marine qui est présent très
présente dans votre livre vous racontez
son éclosion vous la regardez admiratif
lors de ses premières prestations télé
et puis vous êtes de plus en plus dure
jusqu'à la rupture la plus grosse erreur
de marine aura été de m'exclure du front
national c'est une erreur morale en
rompant avec son père à la briser le
lien sacré de piété qui font notre
civilisation en rompant avec le
fondateur du fn elle a cassé un lien
d'amour entre les français et à
eux-mêmes
on a les bras vous n'avez toujours pas
digéré je crois d'un an je n'ai pas
digéré non si objectivement car meys les
années passent mais jean marie le pen ne
change pas on l'avait vu déjà dans le
message qu'il a envoyé lors du décès de
jacques chirac
cet ennemi d'un ennemi une phrase très
très sèche et d'ailleurs dans le livre
il parle de 2002 aussi donc de du
comportement de jacques chirac il a
toujours pas aimé ce qui est là aussi où
il est dur c'est sur marion maréchal ce
qui est plus nouveau
parce que c'est lui qui l'avait poussé à
se présenter aux législatives
on se souvient dans le vaucluse est il
fondé pas mal d'espoirs sur elle et le
fait qu'elle est
renoncer à se présenter en 2010 est que
là elle annonce que valve annonce elle
redit puisque ça on le sait depuis
longtemps qu'elle ne se présentera pas à
la présidentielle de 2000 22 en tout cas
pas contre sa tante marine le pen et on
voit bien là que chez jean marie le pen
salah gas lui c'est kelly les soins
massages déçoit salah gas parce que lui
il a toujours pris des risques c'est
toujours présente et il a eut mis du
temps avant de percer électoralement et
donc au fond il est déçu que marion ne
reprennent pas le flambeau on voit bien
qu'ils pensent au fond de lui même s'il
ne dit pas si clairement que marine le
pen c'est pas cette génération à qui
arrivera à saartjie vous avez envie de
le lire ce livre au delà de ce que vous
pouvez penser du personnage en tout cas
je le trouve qu'ils méritent de figurer
dans les manuels de psychologie
psychanalyse parce que ça c'est un
bonheur sous cet aspect là de l'entendre
c'est quand même à chaque fois un
festival
ben en fait je trouve que c'est celui
qui parle le mieux de marine le pen
parce que finalement ce sont des gars ce
qu'il pointe c'est-à-dire le manque de
hauteur de profondeur de 10 calment de
confiance
oui oui oui tout à fait et puis il dit
aussi que c'est une femme donc qui
manque de contenu de substance les dons
qu'elle va chercher le font chez
d'autres parce que elle elle n'en a pas
et finalement tout ce qu'il décrit week
et qu'elle finalement elle pas lisse et
ses carences en confiance en elle même
et c'est par une gouaille une sens de la
répartie et c'est très juste en fait
c'est ce qui est le portrait qu'il fait
de sa fille correspond exactement à ce
que on aperçu du débat lorsqu'elle est
du débat présidentiel lorsqu'elle était
opposé à emmanuel macron c'est
exactement ça donc je trouve que il est
très juste l'aigreur n'empêche pas une
certaine forme de
voilà d'acuité et que donc c'est
intéressant pour marine le pen d'en
tenir compte
et effectivement je suis assez d'accord
son hommage parce que malgré tout ils
devront quand même aussi hommage à sa
petite fille enfin sa petite radio
mashaal l'open donc c'est mais celle ci
est ambigu il ya vraiment à la fois il
en fait une espèce d'animal politique
et puis en même temps on sent cette
déception et de fait la situation peut
actuelle ne peut que lui donner raison
puisque pour l'instant effectivement son
école c'est trente personnes
y'a pas de corpus idéologique véritable
si ce n'est des des litanies qui n'ont
que tout c'est cette fraction de la
droite quand même réussit depuis pas mal
d'années c'est toujours les mêmes donc
il n'ya pas d'inventivité politique
donc je trouve que finalement c'est
assez juste derrière la logorrhée un peu
vitupérant twiss assez juste alors nos
intérêts ne sont pas encore tout à fait
convaincu puisque à 80% vonau dit non
nous ne lirons pas le tome 2 des
mémoires de jean marie le pen et vos b
est risible
moi je dirais je veux dire eh bien si on
m'offre béchir est pas jusqu à l'acheter
je pense qu'au niveau 80 j'espère que la
wii l'éditeur et je pense que vos 80 %
sion il avait sous les yeux et qu'ils
n'étaient pas obligés de l'acheter il
jettera un oeil dessus et il le parcours
est sans aucun doute
ceci étant j'ai sans doute tort puisque
faisant un peu d'analysé des situations
politiques je devrais lire le tome 2
jean marie le pen
voilà mais je vais avoir un peu de mal à
les acheter florian nous dit je le lirai
à titre informatif il représente une
partie de l'histoire
brownie tôt peut-être que je le lirai
j'ai toujours voulu comprendre mieux la
nausée et les mains sales
au moins c'est clair aaron lennon qu'est
ce que vous en pensez
j'ai pas lu le tome 1 donc je suis pas
l'intention d'y lire le tome 2
c'est pas ça je pense qu'effectivement
enfin voilà en plus comme mais même
au delà des divergences idéologiques que
je peux avoir avec ce monsieur c'est le
commentaire de la vie politique très
immédiate
il y en a tellement que je suis pas la
conviction que le sien apportera quelque
chose de plus de très déterminant ça
fait à peu près depuis le début du gilet
jaune que j'ai arrêté de lire des essais
politiques je n'ai plus que des livres
d'histoire et des romans j'en apprends
beaucoup plus sur l'actualité de cette
façon qu en lisant les tous les tous les
essais politiques et très immédiat
surtout quand on est en plus quand
j'entends et que je lis les extraits
dans la presse pour le coup je les lis
aussi et qu'effectivement ces
dérèglements de coach imagine que s'il
n'y a pas que ça mais c'est des
règlements de comptes au sein de sa
famille c'est pas ce qui me semble être
le plus le plus instructif sur la vie
politique
et dont on pourrait tirer des leçons
structurelles sur l'évolution du pays
seule conclusion peut-être sait que le
talent ans ne se transmet pas
visiblement puisque il a l'air d'avoir
un jugement très dur sur sa fille et sa
petite-fille on sait au fond c'est moi
ça me réjouit plutôt dans ce cas wild et
parise et non plus 1 il est en train de
critiquer sa fille des succès du film et
lui elle a fait bien plus une autre ça
donne ça donc c'est un peu et là on sort
vraiment toute l'amertume d'un père
c'est ça qui lui permet de parler comme
ça de sa fille parce que autrement il
serait capable de l'encenser si elle
l'avait laissé président honoraire
le rassemblement national voilà et bien
voilà deux points de vue l'idée exprimée
c'est à vous maintenant de vous faire le
vôtre merci beaucoup de nous avoir
suivis et point de vue revient bien sûr
demain même heure même endroit
bonsoir à tous
[Musique]